[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE], and I'm part
of the Google Talk Scene,
and I'm also a
developer at Google.
So today, we're going to discuss
Scott and Carolyn's book,
"Wired to Create."
Scott is the Scientific Director
of the Imagination Institute
in the Positive Psychology
Center at the University
of Pennsylvania.
He conducts research on
the measurement and element
of imagination,
creativity, and play,
and teaches the popular
undergrad course,
which is Introduction
to Positive Psychology.
And he's also host of
The Psychology Podcast
and co-founder of
the Creative Post,
and he writes blog
"Beautiful Minds"
in "Scientific American."
Carolyn is New York-based
journalist and author.
She's currently a Senior
Writer at the Huffington Post,
and she reports on
health and science.
Her writing has also appeared
in "Scientific American,"
CNN, and other publications.
And she's discussed her
work on MSNBC, "Today Show,"
and the History Channel.
So please welcome
Scott and Carolyn.
[APPLAUSE]
So their book,
"Wired to Create,"
offers a glimpse
inside the messy minds
of highly creative people.
So let's get started
with book introduction
from Scott and Carolyn.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Thank you.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Hey, guys.
Welcome.
Can you hear me OK, all
the guys over back there?
So yeah, we wrote this book
called "Wired to Create."
I am a scientist.
I've been on this mission
for a very long time,
to understand what is the nature
of human intelligence, what is
the nature of human creativity.
How does it work in the brain?
How can we develop it in people?
How can we appreciate
it more in society?
There seems to be a bias
against creativity in schools
and in certain workplaces--
I assume not Google at all.
You guys seem very progressive.
I just went to the bathroom.
There was a woman right
next to me in the bathroom,
and that was OK.
So it's a very
progressive place.
It's a unisex bathroom.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--to explain that.
And all these sorts
of questions of like,
what is creatively really?
How can we really
promote and stimulate it?
Is it just a soft
skill, or is it
something that is deeper
and more important
Do you want to
introduce yourself?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
So I'm Carolyn.
Scott and I co-wrote this book.
And we were motivated
by all these questions
that Scott mentioned, but
primarily the question of what
makes highly creative people
different from everyone else.
And so this kind of
exploration took us
through decades worth of
personality psychology,
starting with a really
interesting experiment
that was done in the '60s by a
researcher named Frank Barron.
So he invited all
of these eminent
creative minds-- Truman Capote,
William Carlos Williams,
Frank O'Connor-- to
stay in this frat house
on the UC-Berkeley campus.
But they weren't
playing beer pong.
They were doing much
more fun things,
like answering personality tests
and tests of mental illness,
and all kinds of different
examinations of the way
that they think and
feel and behave,
and questions about
their life circumstances.
And what he found was a pretty
big insight at the time,
even though it may not
sound like it today,
that creativity and intelligence
are not the same thing.
So that was kind of the
jumping off point of this book,
is if creativity is
not intelligence,
then what is it, really?
And so we look to
explain the special spark
of creative genius.
And at least in
that study, Barron
found a few central
characteristics, which
were these highly
creative people
were very open to
their own inner lives.
They had a very high tolerance
for disorder, for complexity,
for chaos, for ambiguity.
They had this desire to
make meaning out of chaos.
They were non-conformist.
They were unconventional,
risk-takers.
They were kind of originals
and very individual.
So he found that
this very messy mix
of things, which is
where we kind of got
this idea of-- well,
one of the places we
got this idea of the messy minds
of the highly creative person,
that they can't be boiled
down to one single thing.
It's this complex sort of
host of characteristics
that seem to inform creativity.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Totally.
We want to rebrand having a
messy mind as a good thing.
In schools, we promote
efficiency, right?
We say, OK, well you have
to do well on this test
and you can't revise it.
You have to do well on
this standardized test.
But when we study
these creative geniuses
or these great creators, you
see they're not characterized
by their efficiency.
They're characterized
by their variability.
They're characterized by
their trial and error,
their risk-taking, their
openness to experiences,
their sensitivity.
And a lot of times,
their sensitivity
can seemingly get in the way
of their creative process.
But you find that it
is through reconciling
all of these contradictions
within themselves that you
find creativity is
most likely to emerge.
We also found lots
of contradiction
with introversion
and extroversion.
Raise your hand if
you're an introvert.
No, I'm not going to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
But a lot of you
in this room might
identify-- raise
your hand if you've
read Susan Cain's book "Quiet."
I'll ask that.
Well, you all should
totally read that after you
read "Wired to Create."
She's wonderful, and
she wrote this book
about why it's important
to understand introversion
and what it is, and give
people opportunities
who aren't necessarily the first
one to speak at the meeting,
for instance, or
the one who doesn't
like to be put on the spot,
to come up with answers.
And a big part of
what we learned
through this scientific
investigation of creativity
is that a lot of
great creativity
comes through solitude,
comes through daydreaming.
It comes through
things that we don't
promote in our school system,
and often in the workplace.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
Like Scott was saying,
introversion and exploration
was a central
contradiction that we
explored within a
series of paradoxes
seen in highly creative people.
There was a really
interesting study
done on heavy metal
musicians which
found that they actually are
very sensitive and introverted,
and say things backstage
like they need lots of time
by themselves and they enjoy
daydreaming and engaging
in a world of fantasy, and
that they are easily disrupted
by loud noises-- which is a
very strange thing to hear
from a heavy metal musician.
But again and again in the
lives of different types
of creative people, we see
these very startling contrasts.
So these heavy metal musicians
were very bold and brash
onstage, and that was
very much something
a part of themselves
and something
that they enjoyed doing.
So they did have extroversion
in that sense, and charisma.
But they were also very shy,
very often isolated, sensitive,
introverted.
And so these contradictions are
pretty much across the board
present in people who
have eminent creative work
that they have done.
And this is partly
because-- well, it's
possible that these sort
of inner tensions that we
feel within ourselves give
rise to the desire to create.
And it's actually been found
that creative writers score
both in the top 10% of
the general population
on tests of mental
illness, and also
in the top 15% on
tests of mental health.
So how is that possible?
It may be that people who
are driven to create just
are more open to this
broad sense of themselves,
are more intimate with
both the dark and the light
within themselves.
And that may be
sort of a catalyst
for creative exploration,
for creativity
as a way of trying to
understand themselves.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
We're starting to see
this a bit in the brain.
We're doing neuroscience.
Do we have anyone
in this room who's
interested in
neuroscience at all?
Oh, excellent.
So we found that
three major brain
networks are important
for the creative process.
Traditionally, what's called
the executive attention network
has been considered
the most important one.
And the executive
attention network
involves your ability to
focus on the outside world,
to hold lots of different bits
of information in your head
at once and integrate them.
When you're programming, when
you're really focusing-- let's
say you're going through
like 5,000 lines of code
to find that one mistake.
The executive attention
network is extremely important.
But a very under-rated
brain network
that's been discovered
in recent years
is called the default
mode brain network.
It was discovered accidentally
by a cognitive neuroscience,
because cognitive
neuroscientists weren't
interested in what was
going on in your own head
while you were being part of a
experiment that wasn't related
to the actual experiment.
So if the experimenter
is like, is this line
bigger than this line?
Or comprehend this boring
reading comprehension passage--
any of your daydreaming,
any of your fantasies,
your future
thoughts, strivings--
all that was considered
noise in the laboratory.
Until recently, some really--
am I allowed to say "badass?"
Badass neuroscientists
were like,
we wonder if there's any
value at all to what's
going on by default
in their head.
What is that cognition
when we're not
telling them what to do?
And it opened up this
whole new line of research
in cognitive neuroscience, this
discovery of the default mode
network.
We like to call it
the imagination brain
network, because it turns
out this network is not
just associated with
daydreaming and mind-wandering
and imagination, but
it's also associated
with making meaning out
of your experiences.
When you disrupt
this brain network,
you find that you also see
disruptions in sense of self
and your capacity to create
a narrative about your life
and make meaning.
Of course-- maybe
it's not of course,
but did you know that the
self is a construction?
It's not actually a
thing, a real thing
we discovered physically?
Oh, there's the self.
This is a very age-old question.
But what we do know
is our self-concept.
And it's constantly
being revised.
Our self-concept
is constantly being
revised by other
people's opinions of us
and by our own opinions
of ourselves, which
is very important.
It influences how we engage
with others in the world.
And you find this
imagination is very
important for that
natural process.
So we find those two brain
networks are important.
And there's a
third brain network
that is very under-rated.
It's called the
salience brain network.
And that's associated with your
ability-- not your ability,
but motivation.
How much do things
in your environment
capture your attention?
His salience network wasn't
activated in this talk-- maybe.
I don't know.
But the salience
network is really
important for
helping to tag things
as relevant or irrelevant.
So if you're in a
really boring lecture
or you're in a boring--
most of us in school
were forced to pay
attention to a teacher.
And that salience network
has passed the baton over
to the imagination
network, and that's
when we start daydreaming
and mind-wandering.
But when that
salience network says,
wow, that's really
interesting-- then
it passes the baton over to the
executive attention network,
and that's when we
really can focus.
So in a lot of ways, the
key to everything in life
is activating that
salience network, which
is at a subconscious level.
And it also is influenced
by our learning process
and our past experiences.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
And so where that comes
in with the personality
contradictions is
that in most people,
the external attention network
and the internal default
network are at odds.
We're either using one
or we're using the other,
depending on the situation
and the task at hand.
But in creative people,
something really interesting
is happening-- or when people
are engaged in creative work
and develop these
creative skills,
these brain arcs
actually harmonize,
and there's a rapid sort of
switching between the networks
and people become
very well equipped
at using them together.
So it's kind of
like these opposites
coming together, even on
the level of neurology.
So we see in the level of
the brain and the personality
and the creative process, which
also tends to be kind of back
and forth and is not a linear
progression for most people--
I'm sure many of us can relate
to procrastinating and doing
nothing on a project, and then
suddenly it all comes at once.
Or maybe not you guys.
You made it to Google, so--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Google
can't be shut down for a day
because you guys procrastinated.
We need you.
You've got how many people
million people every 20
seconds?
What does it say up there.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
But even Picasso
late in his career, when he had
made thousands of paintings,
his process still didn't
look to be what you would
expect from a seasoned painter.
He would kind of
go back and forth,
and he would create sketches
that sometimes would have
a sort of linear
progression, and then
he would go back
to the earliest one
and then put that
in the painting.
And it would seem to
be this process more
of blind experimentation
than any sort
of logical, orderly
sort of process.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Let me tell them
about a study that came out
after our book was published
that is really interesting.
We're kind of having a new
understanding of personality
and the way it works.
Raise your hand if you
think the way personality
works is it's something that you
have these stable dispositions
that don't really change that
much throughout your life?
Raise your hand if you
think that's-- OK, good.
Good.
So it turns out that, through
the course of our day--
I feel I can get really
technical with this audience
and you guys will really
get me, so I'm just
going to be technical.
So the way we think
of personality now
is density distributions.
So each one of us has
a density distribution
for a whole wide
range of traits.
But what that means is that it's
kind of like you have a bell
curve throughout
the day of-- no one
is purely extroverted
or purely introverted.
And what you see is
that within a person,
you actually cycle through
every introverted-extroverted
behavior.
At the core we're all human.
So you know how you have people
who say, I'm an introvert
and they're so proud of it, and
they're like, that's who I am.
I'm never an extrovert.
But if you actually follow
them throughout the day,
like scientifically you
follow them throughout the day
and you have them
report their thinking--
you find they actually
extrovert a lot more
than they're willing to admit.
What you do see, though, is
that their density distribution
is skewed much more towards the
interviewed side on average--
not even on average,
just in terms
of the skew of a distribution.
And we're starting
to extend that now
to things that have normally
been non-clinical traits,
like narcissism for instance--
things like schizophrenia.
It actually turns out that
these things were breaking down
the boundaries of what
these things mean between,
oh, there's the clinical
people that we put them
in the mental institution
who have that,
and then there are the rest
of us who are not in clinical.
We're good.
But we're not good,
you Know Or they're
not bad, is how I prefer
a positive spin on it.
And so how this relates is that
when you look at the brain,
you find that actually
there's a lot of similarities
between schizophrenic patients
and creative people when
you ask them to
solve creative tasks.
That's where I'm
going with this.
I wanted to tie it all together.
You actually find there's
a lot of similarities.
Where the differences
are is when
you follow them throughout
the course of the day
and you find that actually,
creative people are
more able to return to reality.
So they're equally as capable
of jumping out and taking a risk
and thinking really
imaginatively
and quote psychotically.
But what they're able to
do throughout their day
is their density
distribution of schizophrenia
is much less skewed to
the one and the other
for schizophrenic patients.
And that's a new emerging way
of thinking about personality
that I think is going to
have profound implications
in the coming years.
Does that make sense?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
And going back to this finding
that creative writers were
sort of both more mentally
ill and more mentally healthy
than other people, I think part
of the mentally ill aspect--
part of the aspect that is
related to mental illness
is so something
called schizotypy
is a spectrum ranging
on one end, which
is sort of imaginativeness
and on the other, full-blown
schizophrenia.
And so what's been
found is highly
creative people
may have just some
of the more positive traits
associated with schizophrenia,
without the more harmful ones.
So that would be things
like magical thinking
and a tendency to see patterns
and to find order and disorder,
and very unusual perceptions
or heightened perceptions.
So maybe if they're
listening to chimes,
they would hear more
sound in the chimes
than the average person would.
And so these are things
that our society associates
with mental illness,
but I've been thinking
of this list of traits.
Do they really seem so
negative, and can that actually
maybe lead us to
reconsider mental illness
and how we treat mental
disorders in our culture?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Absolutely.
Did we want to do a Q&A?
How are we doing on time?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So thank you so much
for the introduction.
Reading your books, there were
some questions I did have.
And then we can have
open Q&A for everyone.
So we generally consider
the creative mind
restricted to a select group of
artists, scientists, writers,
or musicians.
Why do you suggest that
personal creativity
is important for
everyone's sense of being?
It's important for
everyone's sense
of well-being, not just a few
selected creative artists.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
We talk about well-being
in the book a little bit,
so that's an exciting question.
Do you want to cover that?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
I think creativity is just
kind of a natural part of who
we are.
And we see this in the
case of children at play.
Play is not a thing that some
children do and some children
don't.
It's actually a natural and
healthy and very important
part of child development.
And when there is not
play, there's a problem.
And so from that and
from other research,
we can kind of deduce
that creativity is just
a fundamental human
characteristic.
And so it doesn't always
take the form of a Picasso
or a genius musician, but
creativity is just-- I mean,
we define it as-- well, I
guess science defines it as--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: We should
have defined creativity first.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
Science defines it
as novelty and usefulness.
So we kind of define
it broadly as just
bringing something
new into the world,
whether that's a new
idea or just a new way
of seeing a problem, or a new
way of presenting something.
There are so many
forms creativity can
and so many everyday forms
that it does take-- from what
we choose to wear and
put something together
in a different way to the
way that we phrase just even
a sentence in an email
that has a little bit
more personal meaning.
I think everyone is creative,
and you can't really
escape creativity when you
look at it in that sense.
And so the more
we do exercise it
and the more we do bring
new things into the world
and bring some sort
of self-expression
into what we do, generally,
the more joy that we'll
have in our lives.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
There's definitely
research showing
that everyday
forms of creativity
is correlated with
feeling vitality
in life, optimism, a sense
of meaning in your life.
So it's very true.
And at the highest levels,
at the genius level,
it is a myth that mental illness
is required for creativity.
I want to be very
clear about that.
But when you find
is an association,
because a lot of people who
have had very harsh childhood
experiences are
actually overrepresented
in creative fields.
People who've had some
hardships in their childhood
is actually over-represented
in the history books.
And a lot of psychologists
are trying to figure out why.
What's going on there?
Is it that you need
to have hardships
in order to be creative?
And it turns out
that these hardships
create a sense of
otherness in them that
allows them to see a
world in a different way,
allows them to step back.
And also, it gives them more
confidence to take risks,
because they're like, oh,
what do I have to lose?
I've already lost
it all pretty much.
So they're much more
willing to take risks.
And also, another thing is that
a lot of creative people who've
had hardships, there's
an emerging field
called post-traumatic growth
that we talk about in the book.
So a lot of them use their
hardships to grow creatively.
So a lot of creative writers
will put it into their work.
They'll write about
it in their work.
I'm trying to think
right now in my head
how you would put post-traumatic
growth into your code.
I guess you guys can
give me some ideas what
that would like.
How can you take out all
your frustrations on the code
that you're doing?
I'd love to hear that.
But you do find in a whole
wide range of creative fields,
a lot of people have
had these hardships,
and creativity is
healing for them.
There's art therapy.
There's all these
emerging fields where
creativity can be very healing.
We talk about journaling
in the book has
been shown to be really
important for healing trauma.
So I wanted to make that point.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So throughout the
book, you always
mention messy minds and messy
brains, messy emotions--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Everything's messy.
SPEAKER 1: Everything's messy.
So what are the
conflicting mental states
that creativity draws upon
that you can think of?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Well, we were
talking about that a little
bit with the brain activation.
So you have what's called
spontaneous cognition.
You have more
controlled cognition.
You have more reflective.
We talk about intuition in the
book and why that's important,
and drawing on your intuition
to a certain degree,
drawing on your
personal experiences.
We talk about mind-wandering.
Then I'll pass the baton to
you, Carolyn, talk a little bit
about mindfulness.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
So one of the other
contradictions we explored
is mindfulness and daydreaming.
Daydreaming is really
important for creativity,
because it's activating
the default mode network.
So often, we'll come
up with an insight
when the mind is just wandering.
This is why so many
people actually
do come up with great
ideas in the shower,
because it's this place
where your mind is just
kind of mellowing.
But it's still kind of at
work in the background.
You're maybe thinking
about something,
but not too hard, and then
something completely unrelated
comes into your mind.
So daydreaming-- I mean, that's
a whole other can of worms.
But it's very critical
to creative thinking.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: I did an
international study on showers,
and more people reported
creative insights in the shower
than they did at work.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
So day-dreaming
is pretty critical to the
creative thinking processes.
But mindfulness is as well.
It's easy to see how we need
to be able to focus and to pay
attention, and to really sustain
our attention on whatever we're
doing in order to
actually do creative work.
So we kind of need daydreaming
for this idea generation,
and then mindfulness
for actually making
our ideas become a reality.
And so these kind of thinking
processes can be at odds,
but creative people do tend
to find a kind of synthesis
between them.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: With that
said, we debate often a lot
whether expert mindful
people, are they creative?
And that's still a
question open for debate.
But the research is kind
of mixed in that, showing
that too much mindfulness on
the outside world or too much
focus does limit your career
potential in a lot of ways
if you don't have
the flexibility
to go back and daydream as
well about what you've learned.
So that's what we're seeing.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
And actually, certain
types of meditation
are better than others when
it comes to stimulating
creative thinking.
Does anyone practice TM,
transcendental meditation?
No?
I'm surprised.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Does anyone
do meditation in any form?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: So
forms of meditation
that sort of encourage awareness
of the internal thought
processes-- we can be mindful
to actually our own thoughts
and our own imagination.
We usually think of
mindfulness as being
mindful to the external world,
to the present moment in terms
of our immediate surroundings.
But sometimes meditation,
like transcendental meditation
and open monitoring
meditation, encourage
becoming more mindful
of everything that's
in our internal landscape.
So there is an ability
to allow the mind
to wander, to pay
attention to that,
and then to bring it back.
And these types of
meditations, more so
than a very strict,
intense zen meditation
where you're focusing
just very intensely
on some external
object-- these tend
to be more effective
for creativity,
because they're bringing
together those two thinking
processes.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
I would also like to
open the floor for anyone
if you have any Q&A questions.
If not, then OK.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering,
from this knowledge, what
is the actionable
thing that we can do?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
That's a fair question.
Fair question.
Scientists cringe a little bit
when they get that question,
because they're like,
that's not what I do.
It's not what I do.
But people want to know.
And we talk about some
actionable things in this book.
And I think the
best way to think
about it is that creativity is
a way of being in the world.
Don't think of creativity
as only this thing
that geniuses do.
It's a way of relating
to your world.
And we really feel, to the
extent to which you follow
these 10 things
in this book, you
are in effect living
a creative lifestyle.
And you're increasing
the chances
there'll be creative insights.
It's very important
to build time
into your day to have solitude.
Too many meetings is going
to stifle creativity,
if there are any project
managers listening to that.
It's really important to
constantly push yourself out
of your comfort zone.
We have a whole chapter on
openness to new experiences
and how it's going to be
really super important.
Building time to daydream
and reflect, like journal
about your
experiences and really
get a chance to understand that.
What are some other things?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: I think one
of the most important things
is openness to experience,
which we have a big chapter on.
And this is actually
a personality trait
that's the number one predictor
of creative achievement
across all fields
in arts and science.
And so this can take a
lot of different forms.
But really, any sort of
new experiences or new ways
of approaching things,
or even walking
a different way to work--
that sounds so trivial,
but just rewiring
your brain patterns
and getting into
a different state
actually makes a
very big difference,
and it can sort of,
on subtle levels,
and then eventually
on larger levels,
change the way that you think
and give way to new ideas.
So people who have
studied abroad,
they've done studies and
found that they perform better
on tests of creative thinking
after college students study
abroad.
And people who-- what are
some of the other ones?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Immigrants.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
Immigrants tend to bring this
influx of art and culture
into a new place, which
stimulates broader,
societal-wide shifts in thinking
and in art and science and tech
and that kind of thing.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Totally.
The big thing is to keep
cycling through your mindsets,
your modes of thinking.
Keep cycling all
throughout the day.
Don't get stuck.
If you're focusing on a
problem and you're like,
OK, let's stay up all night.
We're going to solve this,
and we're not leaving
till we solve this problem.
That's very unlikely
we're going to solve
the problem that night.
It's really important to
have that time to cycle
through these different
mental states,
because we know that's how
creativity works in the brain.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it sounds like
diversity of new experiences
is really important to
help train creativity.
I think you mentioned journaling
a few different times-- one
as a way to deal with
trauma, and also as a way to,
I think improve creativity.
Did you say that?
Could you elaborate
a little more
on journaling and its effect?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
What it requires is that
you're actively and cognitively
processing what has happened
to you throughout the day,
and that you're making meaning.
You're trying to actually
tie it to your life--
your past experiences,
your future experiences.
Before you go to
bed every night,
we know in positive
psychology it's
good to write and reflect
on the things that
went wrong during the day and
then say, what was the point?
What can I learn from that?
Constantly be in
problem-based mode.
And then also, write
three good things
that you're happy about that
day before you go to bed.
So it's called the three
good things exercise
that I teach my students in
my positive psychology class.
And that makes it
much more likely
that you will wake up the next
day feeling more ready and able
to tackle the day.
And you could see how
that positive emotions--
we know positive
emotions are correlated
with creativity and probability
for creative thinking,
and insightful thinking.
So to the extent to
which you put that
into your journals, that allows
you to have fresh outlooks
and perspectives on life
that's going to increase
your creativity, I would think.
If you want specific exercises,
you can email me, though.
There's some great
stuff by Pennebaker
and others that can get
you started right away.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: By the
way, I went to high school
with these three.
And it's so surreal that
they're sitting there right now.
They're really good friends.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Scott.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Hey.
AUDIENCE: What would you say
makes society value or not
value creativity?
Why are there are so
many starving artists?
Why do you hear about
the painter who becomes
famous only after his death?
Why do we want to consume so
much content, but maybe not pay
for it?
What are some of your
psychology thoughts on that?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: I
think I'm talking a lot.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah, I'll
just jump in really quick.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: I
feel like I'm yakking.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
I think we sort
of value creativity in theory.
We celebrate, obviously,
great musicians
and artists and innovators,
and kind of hold them up
and put them on pedestals.
But we tend to not look at
what it took to actually get
there, and the sort of
challenges that are inherent,
and the failures
that are inherent
to the creative process.
And especially, you see
this in schools for sure,
and also in a lot
of organizations.
I expect that Google is a little
more progressive on this front.
But most organizations say
that they desire innovation,
and that they want
creative new products.
They want creative people.
They want to do
things differently.
But they're actually
completely unwilling to make
the sacrifices
that that requires.
So that's allowing people to
maybe have more freedom, or--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Pretty much choosing
what project you
want to work on.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah,
allowing people to sort of think
about things in a new way, or
kind of write their own rules
in some sense, or
just accepting failure
as a path to doing something
really differently.
So really, I think
in the workplaces
and in schools is where
we see that the most.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
And in schools, for sure.
I mean, we have
this whole culture
of standardized testing.
So we teach to the test.
So we don't have a
revision process.
There's something like, you
got a D. You're like, OK,
I'm screwed.
I got a D. As opposed to,
look, you didn't fail.
You've got a D. So there's still
stuff we can work out here.
They don't frame it
that way in school.
There's so many ways
we could be framing
things that make
school like, oh, this
is all about personal growth.
This is all about--
our book is very much
a personal-growth-oriented
book, I will say.
Do you agree?
This book is not about-- I
have most respect recorded
and everything for my
colleague Angela Duckworth
and the work on grit and all
that-- very important work.
But we also think that
sometimes, the process itself,
without the goal-oriented
aspect of it,
can be even more
conducive to creativity
than being specifically
goal-oriented.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Yeah.
I think also, our
obsession with efficiency
is kind of at odds with
creative work, which
is a bit more meandering
and doesn't always
have a clear outcome.
And this starts so early now.
I think even preschool kids
have so little free time,
like 30% less than
they did in the '70s.
So that's just not really-- if
we want people to sort of let
their minds go and
come up with new things
and change the
paradigm, it's not
going to come from squeezing
activities into slots,
and not trying to write a
book in a really short period
or come up with a new product
in a ridiculously short period,
because you're just
going and going
and moving onto the next thing.
That's just not really--
creativity works
in a completely different way.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: I mean, I
hope this stuff doesn't-- some
of it may sound really corny,
or really like soft, right?
If I said to you, you really
should make in your day
a play break where you
literally-- there's
45 minutes you could
call anyone at work
and be like, let's play Frisbee.
You think that's corny, right?
You'd be like, ugh.
But there is research showing
that actually, the more that
you build a play
mindset into work,
the more that you come back and
you're more likely to actually
solve the problem.
So I think it's stuff that
really matters, even though we
kind of look down on it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed
most of the research
seems to be done on
artists, musicians,
the fields we traditionally
think of as creative.
Is it because it's easy
to study those sorts of--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
They want to studied.
Artists love it.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Tell
me more about myself.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Is the research
done on those manifestations
of creativity applicable
to maybe the sorts
that we're interested
here in terms
of solving technical
or scientific problems?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Totally fair question.
I think so.
I mean, I've looked at
research on the sciences.
So we don't just
look at the arts,
but I've also done
research in the sciences.
And we find that
intellectual curiosity
is a very strong predictor
of creative achievement
in the sciences, much
more than in the arts.
The arts, openness to
experience was more important.
But we find that more
high-level abstract sort
of level of reasoning, level
of intellectual curiosity--
like coming up with lots
of different possibilities
and really being open
in an intellectual way--
is a much better predictor
of scientific achievement.
So we found that.
I don't know if there's any
real in-depth longitudinal
study of computer scientists.
To me, I don't know if
such a study has been done.
Although I lived with a computer
scientist for a couple years,
and I have some case studies.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know if any real-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was curious, have
you encountered any research
on people using
lucid dreaming to tap
into their creative sources?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Oh, the next question's
going to be drugs, isn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
The gateway question is
always the lucid dreaming.
The next one is always LSD.
Admit it, someone
had that waiting.
Lucid dreaming is a
fascinating phenomenon.
And it is possible
to train yourself.
It's not guaranteed
if you train yourself.
But the normal
areas of the brain--
remember I was talking about
the executive attention network?
Well, that's normally
silence when we're dreaming.
And that's why our dreams tend
to be so bizarre, because there
is no higher order of control
that is making it organized.
So it's sort of like
every person for themself
in your dreams-- like anything
goes, and then you wake up
and you're horrified that
you just had that dream.
You're like, I'm not telling
anyone about that one.
But you can actually
train in a lucid way
to activate your
executive attention
network during dreaming.
And it's really
surreal when you do
that, like literally
surreal because you're like,
I'm able to take an active role
in organizing the structure
of this dream right now.
You know what?
I'm going to walk through that
door right now in the dream.
And people can be
trained to do that.
It's fascinating.
Now, you didn't
ask this question,
but I am curious--
the extent to which,
are lucid dreamers
more creative?
And that's an
interesting question,
and I don't think any study
has ever been done on that.
But there is some emerging
research on LSD and creativity,
if anyone's interested in that--
which Carolyn can talk about.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Well, I
was actually just going to--
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Did
he have another question?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
Well, another thing
sleep-related-- or
dreaming-related,
rather-- is hypnagogia
is this state between
sleep and wakefulness.
I don't know if you ever-- this
sometimes happens to me when
I'm meditating,
which probably means
I'm not a very good meditator--
when you are sort of almost
asleep, and your brain
is just in that place
where it's spitting nonsense?
That is actually a really
creatively fertile time,
because your brain
is going into REM,
but it's also cycling
through things
that have happened in the day,
like memories and ideas and all
these things.
So have the benefits
of sleep in terms
of loosening cognitive control,
but then also your mind
is still active.
So a lot of people have
tried to harness this.
I think Dali did some
sort of weird experiment
where he took a nap and
had something roll down
his hand slowly, and then when
it felt like he would wake up
so he caught himself
in that state
before he actually fell asleep.
So that's kind of an interesting
thing to pay attention to.
It can be difficult to remember
the insights of that time,
but it's like your
brain is loosening
the control and the filter,
and more and more is coming in.
So it's worth paying attention
to and exploring a little bit.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: Yeah.
Also, two glasses of wine
improves your creativity,
as well.
It is good to reduce the
executive functions a little
bit, but not completely.
AUDIENCE: So besides
drugs and meditation,
what can you do
to train yourself
to lose control and
become more creative?
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: There
are cutesy little exercises--
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: That's
a really good question.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN: --that
scientists are working on.
Yeah, it is a great question.
The science of creativity
in terms of developing it
is an underdeveloped field.
At the Imagination
Institute where I work,
we've just done a $3
million grant competition
where we had people
from all over the world
try to provide us
with their ideas
on how we can
improve imagination
and measure it as well.
And the results
of those projects,
which are listed on the
Imagination website,
will be out next year.
And we hope-- we've
given them money.
I hope they did
something interesting.
And so we'll see next
year what they found.
But there are some
cutesy exercises.
There are some exercises
where people-- have you
guys heard of de Bono and stuff,
like lateral thinking exercises
and things?
There are exercises you can
do where you can actively
put through a random
word generator
various words, things
that you're working on,
your project's working on.
And then you've got
to, as an exercise,
think of how are these
three related to each other,
and think creatively about that.
The point is that you want
to get your creative juices
stimulated.
That didn't sound good.
But you really want to get
in that-- so much of it
is a mindset.
And you find that
creativity really does get
blocked when you get
too serious, too down
one garden path.
Creativity is like a spreading
activation model in the brain.
You're going to be most
likely do to access the most
remote associations.
So there are exercises you
can do to kind of on-the-spot,
if you feel like you're
getting too down a single path
to stimulate it.
But I hope we can come up
with better things than that.
CAROLYN GREGOIRE: I don't know,
maybe hypnosis or something--
if you're looking specifically
that sort of loosening
that occurs with
psychedelics and dreaming
and that kind of thing,
I can think of maybe
hypnosis and breath work.
But I'm not necessarily
suggesting those things.
But it's an interesting
question, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Well, thank you.
There was one question
that I did have.
So it was once believed that
creativity was restricted
to the right side of the brain.
But the understandings
have changed now.
What else has changed recently,
like after the book was
published or just that
you would want to mention?
CAROLYN GREGOIRE:
That's a good question.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Well really,
what we were talking about,
these large-scale brain
networks is a much
better way of thinking
about how creativity happens
than left-brain, right-brain.
There are some interesting
lateral specialization effects.
So we do know that the
right side of the brain does
tend to process more non-verbal,
artistic, and the left brain
kind of more language.
But with that said, the
whole creative process
seems to draw on these
large-scale brain
networks that operate in
the left and the right side
of the brain.
And so it requires kind
of a whole-brain approach.
I mean, if I could show you
a picture of what creativity
looks like in the brain,
throughout the whole process
it's pretty much every part
is activated at some point.
And that's a nice way to tie
together the whole messy minds
thing, as well.
Just like I said,
your personality--
throughout the
course of your day,
no matter even if you say, I'm
an introvert, or I'm agreeable,
I'm not agreeable.
Even if you think
you're a saint,
even saints, if you follow
them throughout the course
of the day, are jerks sometimes.
So it's constantly cycling all
throughout the thing, and kind
of being open and embracing that
messiness of human personality
structure.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Thank you so much for coming.
It was great talking to you.
It was very helpful.
Thanks a lot, and thank
you, everyone for coming.
SCOTT BARRY KAUFMAN:
Thanks for inviting us.
SPEAKER 1: There's
books in the back.
[APPLAUSE]